Bonjour à tous et à toutes. Cette vidéo
est sponsorisée par Cambly une plateforme
de cours d’anglais en ligne dont j’ai
déjà eu l’occasion de vous parler.
J’avais même pu tester un cours en ligne,
qui s'était super bien passé.
Sur Cambly, les tuteurs sont très bienveillants
et sont là pour répondre à un besoin précis que
vous leur soumettez, par exemple : préparer un
entretien d’embauche, une expatriation/erasmus,
travailler son accent. Bref, c’est du cours
sur-mesure en fonction de vos besoins et
de vos envies. C’est une plateforme très
pratique, tant au niveau de la réservation
d’un cours que des contenus proposés. Vous
pouvez même suivre des sessions en groupe si
cela répond mieux à ce que vous cherchez.
Avec ce lien vous pouvez essayer Cambly,
vous avez 15 mn gratuites sur un cours
particulier et 50 % de réduction sur
l’abonnement 12 mois (valable autant sur les
cours individuels que les cours en groupes).
Le lien est à retrouver dans la barre
de description, en dessous de la vidéo.
Héritier, Descola, Duflo, Latour…Vous connaissez
peut-être tous leurs noms (ou peut-être pas et
c’est pas grave), mais il est souvent difficile
de résumer quelques concepts-clés ou de savoir
ce qu’ils ont apporté à leur champ de recherche…
Dans une première vidéo, on avait présenté quatre
chercheurs pour quatre disciplines des sciences
humaines : Emile Durkheim, Claude Lévi-Strauss,
André Leroi-Gourhan et Michelle Perrot.
Comme le format vous avait plu, on va donc
continuer notre revue des intellectuels français
influents, et rappeler rapidement leur principales
contributions à la recherche. Bien sûr, vous
vous en doutez, impossible d’être exhaustif,
mais je vous propose les ouvrages les plus
accessibles pour que vous complétiez vous-même,
et tous les autres livres utilisés pour
faire cette vidéo sont dans la barre d’info.
Les quatre personnages qu’on a choisi de
vous présenter ont le point commun d’avoir
remis en question des notions qu’on prenait
souvent pour définitivement acquises. Leur
effort pour redéfinir les termes du débat
ont été importants et particulièrement
féconds pour leurs disciplines. On
commence avec Françoise Héritier.
Décédée en 2017,
à l’âge de 83 ans, Françoise Héritier a marqué
la recherche en anthropologie et ses travaux
continuent de peser dans les débats sur les droits
des femmes. On la connaît en particulier pour son
travail sur les catégories de masculin et de
féminin et les différences entre les sexes.
Elle a aussi tiré les conséquences de son œuvre
théorique et a milité pour les combats féministes.
Françoise Héritier a commencé sa carrière en
1957 au Burkina Faso en tant que géographe
pour une étude d’aménagement. Elle bifurque
vers l’ethnologie pour étudier la population
Samo qu’elle a rencontré sur le terrain et dont
le système de parenté l’intrigue. Un système de
parenté c’est la manière dont une société
organise les mariages et les filiations.
C’est généralement composé d’interdictions,
c’est le tabou de l’inceste par exemple, mais
aussi de recommandations, quelles sont les bonnes
personnes à épouser. Selon les sociétés cela peut
être relativement simple ou bien extrêmement
alambiqué et c’est l’un des dadas favoris des
anthropologues. Et il se trouve que les Samo
qui intéressent Françoise Héritier ont une
parenté dite de type Omaha, un système à l’époque
inconnu en Afrique et qui méritait investigation.
Héritier réalise donc une vaste enquête et
établit une base de données informatique
dans laquelle elle recense plus de mille
mariages. C’est notamment ce travail qui
lui permettra de lui succéder au Collège de
France en 1982 à la chaire d’anthropologie.
Mais au-delà de la question de la parenté sur
laquelle elle a rédigé sa thèse de doctorat,
Françoise Héritier commence à s’intéresser aux
questions de différences entre les sexes. Car
dans les systèmes de parenté qu’elle
observe, les hommes et les femmes ne
sont pas égaux dans les interdictions
ou les liens de filiation. Elle réalise
que les interdictions matrimoniales dans les
systèmes de parenté sont toujours formulées
au masculin : “un homme ne peut pas épouser
telle femme”, mais on ne dit jamais l’inverse.
Il n’y a pas de réciproque et on peut finalement
distinguer une “valence différentielle des sexes”.
Ce concept-clé qu’elle forge se trouve selon elle
au fondement des sociétés. Et cette valence est
toujours au bénéfice des hommes. Même dans les
sociétés matrilinéaires comme chez les Iroquois,
où les femmes veuves, en tant que cheffes
de lignages pouvaient acquérir un pouvoir
assez considérable, cela ne va jamais jusqu’à
l’exercice du pouvoir politique, ni à l’égalité
avec les hommes. Autrement dit, le matriarcat
n’existe pas, et le patriarcat est universel.
Héritier s’est interrogé sur l’origine de
cette institution. Elle reconnaît que la
différence des sexes est un “butoir ultime
de la pensée”, elle est omniprésente dans
le monde animal et les premiers humains ont
pu observer que chaque espèce a des mâles
et des femelles. On constate par ailleurs que
cette séparation fondamentale sert de support
aux autres distinctions telles que haut/bas,
sain/malsain, plein/vide, lumineux/obscur,
chaud/froid, etc. Ces oppositions binaires
permettent de penser le même et le différent
et sont à la base de l’esprit humain.
Partout, ces catégories associées au
masculin ou au féminin sont hiérarchisées. Le
masculin étant toujours supérieur et valorisé,
c’est un invariant. Pour autant, rien ne
fonde, en soi, une infériorité des femmes.
Pour Françoise Héritier, il est indispensable
de prendre en compte les données physiologiques,
puisque c’est finalement tout ce qui distingue
les hommes et les femmes. Le moindre poids,
taille et force physique des femmes aurait donc
un rôle important dans cette conception de leur
infériorité. Mais c’est aussi et surtout le
rôle des femmes dans la procréation qui en
est l'origine selon elle. C’est parce que les
femmes ont le pouvoir de procréer les enfants
des deux sexes, ce qui est souvent expliqué par
la mythologie comme une punition pour les hommes,
que cette valence différentielle est apparue.
Indispensables aux hommes pour se reproduire,
les femmes ont acquis un rôle de ressource
rare, qu’on contrôle et qu’on s’échange.
C’est pourquoi la contraception est
aussi importante pour Françoise Héritier,
c’est un pas de géant vers l’égalité puisqu’elle
donne aux femmes le contrôle de leur corps et
de leur existence :
En devenant des partenaires et non plus des ressources
qu’on s’échange, elles ont leur mot à dire.
Héritier a été pour cette raison une militante
de la contraception et des droits des femmes
dont elle a souvent dit qu’il fallait continuer de
les défendre pour éviter tout retour en arrière.
Ce changement matériel de la place et du
rôle des femmes dans la procréation doit
logiquement agir sur les représentations et
finalement sur l’ordre social selon elle,
c’est une suite logique. Certes, de cet acquis
technique, la contraception, n’a pas découlé
immédiatement une grande révolution, mais il
s’est initié un grand processus de transformation.
A la fin du deuxième volume de son livre le plus
cité, Masculin/Féminin, et dont le sous-titre est
d’ailleurs “Dissoudre la hiérarchie”, elle
propose des solutions ou du moins des pistes
pour l’avenir. Ce qu’il reste à accomplir c’est à
démolir la hiérarchie entre les sexes et que nous
calquons sur les enfants dès le plus jeune âge.
Démolir la hiérarchie, pas démolir la distinction,
il n’est pas question d’uniformisation asexuée.
Héritier parle “d’égalité au sein d’une différence
sexuée, reconnue, acceptée et non hiérarchisée.”
C’est à cette seule condition que les progrès en
matière de droits seront définitivement acquis.
Le deuxième chercheur qui nous intéresse,
Philippe Descola, est aussi un anthropologue
et le successeur de Françoise Héritier au
Collège de France… qui avait elle-même succédé
à Lévi-Strauss, vous suivez ? Né en 1949, Philippe
Descola étudie d’abord la philosophie à l’ENS,
mais échoue à l’agrégation. Peu importe, c’est
déjà l’anthropologie qui l’attire. Après un
stage de quelques mois au Mexique, il se rend
en Equateur et entre en contact avec les Achuar,
un peuple qui vit dans la forêt amazonienne et
qu’on connaît souvent sous le nom de Jivaro,
réputé pour être de dangereux chasseurs de têtes.
Descola réalise trois ans de terrain auprès d’eux
entre 1976 et 1979 pour sa thèse de doctorat,
sous la direction de Claude Lévi-Strauss.
Il publie son travail pour le grand
public dans la collection Terre Humaine,
avec pour titre : Les lances du crépuscule. C’est
une monographie sur la population qu’il a étudiée,
assez classique dans sa structure. Il y décrit les
différents aspects de la culture, la subsistance,
les relations familiales, les guerres avec les
tribus voisines et les cérémonies religieuses.
Mais la formation en philosophie de Descola
se ressent dans cet ouvrage, il est à mille
lieues des ethnologues des années 1970 un peu
naïfs et plus ou moins hippies qui imaginaient
les amérindiens comme de bons sauvages et dont
l’Occident n'aurait qu’à s’inspirer. Descola,
au contraire, a une œuvre conceptuelle
et rigoureuse, qui cherche à comprendre
les manières d’être au monde. Dit comme ça, ça a
l’air un peu pompeux, mais c’est bien de ça qu’il
s’agit : quelles sont les différentes manières
de faire partie du monde. Il faut expliquer.
Son travail de terrain a fait émerger un thème
qui le suivra le reste de sa vie de chercheur,
celui de la séparation entre nature et culture.
Car chez les Achuar, la nature est personnifiée,
elle possède sa propre intentionnalité, et les
humains ont de nombreuses interactions avec elle.
Le vocabulaire de la nature déborde d’ailleurs
largement du cadre strictement objectif et sert
régulièrement à décrire les relations entre les
humains. Descola comprend alors que la dichotomie
entre nature et culture n’est plus tenable
pour étudier le mode de pensée de nombreuses
sociétés. Si l’on souhaite comprendre réellement
leur expérience du monde, il faut se départir de
cette séparation qui n’a pas de sens pour eux.
C’est dans cette optique qu’il rédige son
œuvre majeure : Par-delà nature et culture, publié
en 2005. C’est un bon gros pavé de 550 pages,
rigoureux, théorique, très exigeant… Ne vous
lancez pas là-dedans si vous n’avez jamais lu
d’anthropologie. Mais par contre, si vous avez
le courage, c’est passionnant. Dans ce livre,
Descola détaille quatres différentes manières
de voir le monde ou modes d’identification,
ce qu’il nomme des ontologies. Pour
lui, en fait, il y a quatre manières
de penser les relations entre les humains et les
non-humains, de définir les frontières entre soi
et autrui. On va les passer en revue rapidement.
L’animisme d’abord, qui humanise les plantes et
les animaux, avec qui il est possible d’établir
une communication. Tous les êtres existants sont
différents par leur forme, mais sont identiques
spirituellement. Les humains sont par essence,
comme les animaux et les plantes. Le totémisme
ensuite, mélange les identités des humains et des
non-humains, on peut être identique ou différent,
et ça n’a rien à voir avec la ressemblance. Le mot
kangourou peut aussi bien désigner l’animal que
le groupe dont c’est le totem, sans qu’ils soient
pensés comme différents. Certains humains sont
identiques à certains animaux, mais tout aussi
différents d’autres humains que ne le sont les
espèces animales entre elles. Je sens que je
suis en train de vous perdre… Moi par exemple,
mon animal-totem, c’est la langouste. Dans cette
optique, je suis littéralement une langouste. Et
bien je n’ai rien à voir avec les humains dont
le totem est le pingouin. Ce sont des pingouins,
je suis une langouste, nous sommes radicalement
différents. Faut aller au-delà des apparences…
Le troisième, l’analogisme en est le miroir en quelque sorte, il relie toutes les choses selon
leurs ressemblances.
S’il y a une ressemblance,c’est forcément qu’il y a un lien entre les
choses, ça ne peut pas être une coïncidence.
C’est le mode de pensée qui permet l’astrologie
ou la théorie des humeurs, en bref c’était le
mode de pensée dominant au Moyen-âge et à la
Renaissance, en Orient comme en Occident. Enfin,
quatrième et dernière ontologie, le naturalisme
est le mode de pensée dominant en Occident, c’est
ce qui consiste à couper nettement l’humain du
reste des espèces, de séparer nature et culture.
A la lecture de ces quatre manières de penser
le monde, on comprend finalement que la nature
est dans tous les cas une construction sociale,
même pour nous qui la pensons comme une réalité
extérieure. En conclusion de Par-delà nature et
culture, Descola fait des différentes ontologies
l’explication des inégalités techno-économiques
entre les sociétés. La plupart des sociétés, qui
ne sont pas naturalistes, suppriment les effets
du changement, c’est ce que Lévi-Strauss appelait
des sociétés froides. On en avait parlé dans une
vieille vidéo sur la démocratie… Bon par contre,
y’avait pas de micro, allez voir ça c’est
un peu faire l’archéologie de Passé sauvage…
Contrairement à ces sociétés qui suppriment les
effets du changement, la société industrielle a,
par une série d’objectivations successives,
détaché la nature pour fonder une relation de
domination nouvelle, permettant une exploitation
de toutes les ressources et un progrès technique.
Dans son article “Pourquoi les Indiens d’Amazonie
n’ont-ils pas domestiqué le pécari ?”, Descola
rappelle qu’en vertu de leur animisme, certains
peuples ne peuvent pas envisager les animaux comme
des ressources à domestiquer et exploiter, puisque
ce sont pour eux des sujets et non des objets.
On s’arrête là pour Descola, c’est passionnant,
mais c’est aussi très complexe, il faut le dire.
Il a depuis appliqué son analyse aux paysages, ou
aux images et à l’art dans Les Formes du visible,
un peu comme Lévi-Strauss l’avait fait dans La
voie des masques. En 2011, il a publié un ouvrage
un peu plus court, qui synthétise ses réflexions,
ça s’appelle L’écologie des autres. Alors par
contre, j’ai dit plus court, j’ai pas dit
forcément plus facile, ça reste un peu intense,
mais c’est sans doute le mieux pour commencer.
Troisième chercheuse Esther Duflo, bien plus
jeune, puisqu’elle est née en 1972. Elle est
connue pour avoir obtenu en 2019 le prix de la
banque de Suède, qu’on appelle souvent le prix
Nobel d’économie. Elle a été récompensée pour
ses travaux sur la lutte contre la pauvreté,
en même temps que Michael Kremer et
Abhijit Banerjee, ce dernier étant
son ancien professeur et aussi son conjoint.
Diplômée en histoire et économie à l’Ecole normale
supérieure, Duflo a obtenu un doctorat d’économie
au MIT en 1999, et y a ensuite enseigné. Elle a
dirigé des enquêtes et des actions concrètes dans
de nombreux pays, et a fondé le J-PAL en 2003,
un laboratoire d’action contre la pauvreté. Et
elle est par ailleurs professeure au Collège de
France. (Je vous jure cette vidéo n’est pas
sponsorisée par le Collège de France, c’est
juste que beaucoup de chercheurs importants y sont
recrutés. Après si le Collège de France veut faire
un partenariat, moi je dis pas non hein…)
Si on traite d’Esther Duflo ici, c’est
parce qu’elle a une démarche très intéressante
d’économie expérimentale. Sa démarche consiste
en fait à tester des mécanismes sur le terrain,
pour se départir des clichés et idées préconçues
et lutter efficacement contre la pauvreté.
Il est vrai que l’économie est une discipline dans
laquelle l’idéologie a un poids considérable.
Les remèdes proposés à un même mal par deux
économistes peuvent être totalement opposés.
Car quand on étudie des effets macroéconomiques,
mille phénomènes viennent interférer avec
ce qu’on essaye d’observer, et quand il
s’agit de faire le tri dans les nombreuses
causes entremêlées, le filtre idéologique
du chercheur devient très influent.
Pour minimiser cela, Duflo propose
elle des expériences contrôlées, à des échelles
relativement petites, pour étudier un mécanisme
particulier et obtenir des réponses concrètes.
Dans l’introduction de Repenser la pauvreté,
livre qu’elle a coécrit avec Abhijit Banerjee,
elle explique :
Duflo montre que les choix économiques des
populations pauvres ne sont pas irrationnels
comme on l’a trop souvent avancé. Au contraire,
être contraint de vivre avec moins d’1$ par jour,
c’est développer une économie complexe et
faire des choix prudents pour parvenir à
survivre. Car en plus, l’extrême pauvreté est
le plus souvent synonyme d’exclusion du circuit
institutionnel. Pour les populations les plus
pauvres, impossible de faire valoir ses droits,
ou d’apprendre correctement à l’école.
Pour enclencher une sortie de la pauvreté,
il faut donc une aide, un coup de pouce au départ.
Seulement, de très nombreuses manières de procéder
ont été proposées et les économistes s’affrontent
depuis des décennies pour savoir laquelle est la
bonne, en particulier autour de la question
de l’aide internationale. Pour certains,
une aide financière extérieure enferme
les pays pauvres dans une dépendance et
cela aggrave le problème, tandis que pour
d’autres, c’est la seule solution possible.
Duflo tente de répondre à cette question,
mais pas de manière simpliste et théorique,
elle divise le problème en plus petits enjeux
et conduit des expériences sur le terrain.
L’inspiration lui provient notamment
des expérimentations de Santiago Lévy,
ministre des finances mexicain entre 1994
et 2000 et ancien professeur d’économie à
l’université de Boston, qui a montré que des
transferts monétaires soumis à conditions ont
une réelle efficacité. Les familles qui envoyaient
leurs enfants à l’école étaient récompensées par
des sommes d’argent et cela a permis une hausse
significative de la scolarisation. Cet exemple
mexicain a ensuite essaimé dans le monde entier.
Un programme dérivé, mis en place au Malawi,
a finalement montré que les conditions de l’aide
n'avaient pas d’importance. Donner de l’argent
sans rien exiger en retour a exactement
les mêmes effets : dès qu’ils le peuvent,
les parents envoient leurs enfants à l’école.
Duflo cite aussi souvent l’exemple de Pascaline
Dupas de l’Université de Californie, qui a conduit
une telle expérimentation avec les moustiquaires
au Kenya. Faut-il les distribuer gratuitement
pour toucher le plus de monde ou les faire payer
pour faire prendre conscience aux gens de leur
valeur ? La conclusion est sans appel, ce sont
les distributions gratuites avec une information
ciblée qui ont les meilleurs résultats.
Pour répondre à la question fondamentale
“comment dépenser l’argent ?”, Esther Duflo
utilise donc le modèle des essais aléatoires
de médecine. Un groupe reçoit une aide,
et un autre groupe témoin n'en reçoit pas. En
multipliant les expériences dans plusieurs pays,
il devient possible de comprendre divers
aspects particuliers, pour essayer de créer
des programmes qui marcheraient partout, ou au
contraire qui s’adapteraient aux spécificités
locales. L’ambition est claire, sortir du marasme
des trois “i” : idéologie, ignorance et inertie.
Les travaux de Duflo montrent qu’avec les bonnes
méthodes, des dépenses très modestes touchent
beaucoup de personnes et ont des effets concrets.
Pour mieux comprendre, il faut prendre un exemple.
Esther Duflo a notamment travaillé sur
le microcrédit, c’est-à-dire les prêts
de petites sommes aux personnes qui n’ont
pas accès au système bancaire classique et
qui voulaient développer une activité. Ce
système de financement qui est né en Inde
et au Bengladesh à l’initiative de Muhammad
Yunus ou Padmaja Reddy a été d’abord encensé,
considéré comme le miracle absolu pour sortir le
tiers-monde de la pauvreté, et Muhammad Yunus a
même obtenu le prix Nobel de la paix pour cela en
2006. Puis, la pauvreté n’ayant pas disparu, et
quelques problèmes faisant surface, le microcrédit
a été vivement critiqué. Comme pour d’autres
solutions prétendument miraculeuses, Duflo a
voulu tester scientifiquement son efficacité.
Elle a, pour cela, sélectionné aléatoirement
104 quartiers de la ville d’Hyderabad,
dans le sud de l’Inde, et mesuré les effets
sur les familles. La conclusion est que les
effets sont assez modérés. Cela permet une
amélioration modeste des conditions de vie,
et aide ceux qui ont déjà un petit commerce,
mais le microcrédit ne permet pas un changement
radical et n’est pas une solution miracle pour
sortir de la pauvreté. Elle a aussi investigué
les méthodes de crédit traditionnel auprès
des usuriers et tenté de comprendre leur
succès malgré les taux d’intérêts colossaux
qu’ils pratiquent. Cette analyse, qui est
présentée dans La Politique de l’autonomie, balaie
beaucoup de clichés sur l'irrationalité supposée
des populations pauvres qui semblent,
vu de loin, agir contre leurs intérêts.
Voilà, on va déjà s’arrêter là pour les travaux
d’Esther Duflo, mais vous pouvez facilement en
savoir plus sur la question puisque tous les cours
du Collège de France sont filmés et disponibles
gratuitement, sur leur site et sur Youtube. Je
vous mets en description le lien pour accéder
aux leçons qu’elle a donné cette année, c’est
clair, c’est précis, c’est concret et il n’y a
pas besoin d’avoir un doctorat en économie pour
suivre, donc n’hésitez pas, c’est passionnant.
Alooooooors… Bruno Latour. Un gros morceau pourfinir.
Disparu en octobre 2022, Bruno Latour fait
depuis quelque temps l’objet d’une vénération tout
à fait… étonnante. Cela vient en partie du fait
qu’il était plus lu aux Etats-Unis qu’en France,
et que ça a donné l’impression aux Français,
toujours un peu chauvins, qu’ils étaient passés à
côté de quelque chose. Il est vrai que son travail
foisonnant s’est dirigé vers des sujets variés,
mais dans les dernières années de sa vie et
depuis sa mort, Latour a surtout été cité pour
son travail sur le vivant et l’environnement. On
va pas se le cacher, il fait même carrément figure
de nouveau gourou pour une gauche écologiste
modérée en quête d’un socle théorique.
La première fois que j’ai découvert
Latour, c'était dans ce bouquin : “De
la préhistoire aux missiles balistiques”,
un ouvrage collectif qu’il a dirigé avec
Pierre Lemonnier, mais dont il n’a rédigé que
l’introduction. Le bouquin est vachement bien,
dedans y’a d’ailleurs l’article de Philippe
Descola sur le pécari dont on a parlé, mais
j’avais jamais lu autre chose de Bruno Latour.
Donc c’est l’occasion, on va découvrir très
rapidement son œuvre, et prendre un peu de
temps pour comprendre la passion qu’elle suscite
et aussi les critiques qu’on peut lui porter.
Latour a d’abord soutenu une thèse en théologie.
Vous vous doutez que c’est pas forcément de ça
dont on va parler ici. Il a aussi été agrégé de
philosophie et a ensuite travaillé en tant
que sociologue, auprès d’un laboratoire de
l’Institut Salk à San Diego en Californie, ou plus tard, auprès du
Conseil d’Etat en France. Dans ces études sociologiques, Latour
s’est distingué notamment pour son attention aux
détails, pour son observation rigoureuse des lieux
et des techniques utilisées, à la manière d’un
ethnologue en immersion chez une lointaine tribu
tropicale. Disposition des meubles, organisation
des fournitures de bureau, emploi du temps précis,
il s’est employé à révéler tous les aspects
matériels qui peuvent paraître évidents ou
inutiles mais qui trahissent le fonctionnement
réel de ces institutions. En pointant le rôle de
l’organisation matérielle, Latour montre que
tout n’est pas fait d’idées pures, et que le
plus grand juriste du conseil d’Etat ne peut pas
travailler correctement si le secrétaire est en
panne de chemises cartonnées ou de trombones.
Dans le champ de la sociologie des sciences,
Latour a donc œuvré à montrer comment se fabrique
la science : les relations entre les chercheurs,
la manière dont on rédige un article scientifique
ou dont s’établit un consensus scientifique. Tout
est conditionné par des structures sociales,
mais pas que. Car Latour ne s’est pas contenté
de cette vision, somme toute assez classique.
Pour lui, il faut aussi considérer le rôle des
acteurs qu’il appelle “non-humains” dans
cette fabrique de la science. Les données,
les chiffres et le matériel ont une action
propre. Même si les scientifiques ont le pouvoir
de les remettre en question, ils ne le font que
parfois, et le reste du temps, ces non-humains
ont une influence en eux-mêmes. La science
n’est certes pas qu’une série de découvertes
absolues et cumulées, mais elle ne peut pas
non plus être expliquée que par son contexte
social. C’est quelque part entre les deux.
En somme, Latour a relativisé le relativisme.
Il applique cette méthode aux recherches de
Louis Pasteur dans Pasteur : guerre et paix des
microbes, mais la réception est très mitigée chez
ses collègues, qui ont du mal à voir où il veut
en venir. Certains sont même hostiles et pensent
que cela ne mène à rien, affirmant que c’est “de
l’obscurantisme élevé en principe de méthode
générale”.
Lasociologie des sciences qu’il propose a été
vivement critiquée pour son aspect relativiste
et la formulation excessive de concepts, qui ont
plus tendance à noyer le débat qu’à l’élever. On
l’a donc très souvent qualifié de “post-moderne”,
ce qui n’est pas vraiment un compliment dans la
bouche de beaucoup d’universitaires.
C’était cet aspect sociologique que je
connaissais de son travail à l'époque. C’est très
intéressant, mais ce n’est pas pour ça qu’on cite
Latour à tour de bras aujourd’hui. Car il s’est
ensuite attelé à un enjeu mondial et bien plus
pressant, celui de la crise écologique. Et il
faut essayer de comprendre l’engouement actuel.
Latour insiste sur la menace existentielle,
totalement nouvelle dans l’histoire humaine que
constitue la crise écologique. Dans Politiques
de la nature, Où atterrir ?, ou Face à Gaïa,
il imagine des manières de considérer le problème
et des pistes pour le résoudre, notamment en
donnant une voix aux non-humains, comme les océans
ou les sols. Mais Latour ne fournit pas de feuille
de route précise. Il veut seulement faire émerger
un mode de pensée qui permettrait le changement.
Avec le concept de “cosmopolitique”, qu’il
emprunte à Isabelle Stengers, il veut abandonner
la distinction entre nature et politique, qui
empêche de penser correctement la crise actuelle.
Un peu à la manière d’un Descola qui a remis en
question nature et culture. Pour Latour, l’une
des raisons de l’échec de l’écologie politique est
qu’elle continue de les opposer : “sous couvert de
protéger la nature, les mouvements écologiques
ont aussi conservé la conception de la nature
qui rend impraticable leur combat politique.”
Latour appelle l’écologie à sortir du modernisme,
à arrêter de penser la nature comme un objet
extérieur, la pratique politique montre bien que
les objets sont interconnectés et débordent les
uns sur les autres, l’écologie doit donc assumer
et affirmer haut et fort que l’ordre naturel
est totalement, intrinsèquement politique.
Exercice difficile que de résumer en
quelques phrases la pensée de Latour
sur ces questions car elle remplit des livres
entiers et fait preuve de beaucoup de nuances,
impossibles à rendre ici en si peu de temps. Pour
comprendre tout de même un peu mieux les débats
actuels autour de son œuvre, on peut prendre
le temps de lire une critique, celle formulée
par l’économiste et philosophe Frédéric Lordon.
Dans un article de septembre 2021 publié dans
le Monde diplomatique, Lordon reproche à
Latour et aux latouriens de “pleurnicher
le vivant” au lieu de le penser, et de ne
jamais tirer les enseignements en termes de
politique et d’économie. En somme une pensée
abstraite et qui ne se donne pas les moyens
d’agir. Une philosophie pour bobo, qui est fier
d’être “concerné” par la question du vivant,
mais rien de plus, ne disant jamais rien du
rôle du modèle de production capitaliste.
Lordon conclut :
Les reproches de Lordon ressemblent
beaucoup à ce que décrivait Jean-Paul Sartre
dans son Plaidoyer pour les intellectuels en
1972. Latour et ses disciples endosseraient ici
le rôle des “faux intellectuels” qui proposent
des postures morales et idéalistes,
tandis que les “vrais intellectuels”,
seraient eux, engagés, radicaux et conscients
du rapport de force concret qui est en jeu.
Si certains sont si critiques envers
Bruno Latour, c’est que le problème est
urgent et existentiel. Ce n’est pas qu’un débat
d’universitaires. Si l’on souhaite arrêter
d’empirer les choses, c’est maintenant que ça se
joue, pas plus tard. Pas le temps de s’envoyer
des concepts à la tronche pendant cinquante ans.
Et les écrits de Latour peuvent apparaître comme
trop nébuleux et théoriques, à mille lieux de
l’indispensable action radicale. Latour a sans
doute eu le mérite de penser un cadre nouveau,
d’imaginer la transformation des esprits,
mais il est vrai qu’il ne parle pas d’action.
A la fin de son livre Politiques de la nature,
il dit seulement : “A la célèbre question « Que
faire ? », il n’y a qu’une seule réponse : « De
l’écologie politique ! »”. Pas très satisfaisant
pour qui cherche un guide à son action.
Mais Latour n’a sans doute pas voulu endosser ce
rôle. S’il l’avait souhaité, peut-être n’aurait-il
pas été suivi d’ailleurs. De toute façon les
militants et activistes pour le climat n’ont
pas besoin qu’on leur dicte les bonnes méthodes
depuis des livres ou des vidéos de vulgarisation.
Voilà c’est la fin de ce petit marathon, ça laisse
un petit goût de frustration de pas pouvoir en
dire plus à chaque fois, mais ça permet au moins
de faire découvrir à ceux qui ne connaissaient
pas. De toute façon on reviendra très probablement
sur ces personnages au gré des prochaines vidéos,
donc rien n’est perdu. N’hésitez pas à aller voir
les conférences en libre accès, vous avez les
liens en-dessous, et la bibliographie bien sûr.
Je vous rappelle que Cambly, la plateforme de cours d’anglais en ligne, vous offre une session de 15 minutes gratuite pour essayer un cours. Il vous suffit de suivre ce lien :
Vous aurez également une réduction de 50% sur l’abonnement 12 mois.
Merci à eux d’avoir sponsorisé l’épisode du jour.
à la prochaine !